On June 22nd, 2026, China's Ministry of Commerce published a short list.
10 American companies, no press conference, no warships, no missiles, just 10 names,
and one word next to them. Restricted. Two of those companies mine and process the
material inside American fighter jets, wind turbines, and electric motors. Within days,
the one country that turns their raw material into something a factory can actually use
simply stopped signing their paperwork. China didn't invade anyone, it didn't need to,
it just stopped stamping a form. Every phone in your pocket, every wind turbine spinning over
the North Sea, every MRI machine, every electric motor, every precision-guided
missile built in the last 20 years. All of it depends on 17 elements almost nobody
outside a chemistry classroom can name, and on one country's willingness to keep processing them.
This is a story about the stamp, about how the world built its entire technological future
on top of a paperwork choke point, and pretended it was a mining problem.
Rare Earths aren't actually rare. They're scattered through the Earth's crust almost everywhere,
in tiny concentrations, always mixed together, never alone.
Seventeen elements, chemically almost identical, clumped at the bottom of the periodic table
where most people's eyes glaze over. Digging them up is the easy part,
separating one from the other is not. Think less mining and more baking a souffle
at industrial scale, in acid 500 times in a row without ruining a single batch.
That's what it takes to turn a shovel of mixed ore into one pure element, pure enough to build
anything with. China mines about 60% of the world's rare Earth ore. That's the part most people picture.
It's not the part that matters. China refines close to 90% of it, the step that turns rock
into raw material. And when that raw material becomes the strongest magnets on Earth,
the kind small enough for a phone and strong enough for a fighter jet, 94% of that final step
happens in China too. Twenty years ago it was half that. Nobody declared war to get there,
they just kept building refineries while everyone else kept mining rocks and shipping them east.
An auto worker in Michigan building electric motors, a wind turbine technician in Denmark,
a radiologist in Sao Paulo waiting on a replacement part for an MRI machine.
None of them have ever seen a rare Earth refinery.
All of them are one stamp away from a shutdown. There is no meaningful alternative supply chain,
not because the rock is scarce, because almost nobody else ever learned to finish it.
In 1992, Deng Xiaoping toured southern China
and said something that Beijing never stopped repeating internally.
The Middle East has oil, China has rare earths.
At the time it sounded almost like a joke, the United States, not China, dominated this industry.
A single mine in the California desert called Mountain Pass
supplied practically the entire non-communist world with rare earths for three straight decades.
From the 1950s into the 1980s.
America built the modern magnet industry and barely noticed it had a chokehold on it.
Then China undercut the price, not by a little, by enough that mining and refining rare earths
in America stopped being profitable at all. Environmental rules that didn't apply the
same way in China made the math even easier. Through the 1990s and into the 2000s,
the industry didn't get stolen. It got outcompeted, quietly, one contract at a time.
Until Mountain Pass' own refining line shut down in 1998, a toxic spill closed the whole
site in 2002 and nobody in Washington thought it was worth reopening.
Mountain Pass did reopen in 2018. It's mining again. It produces roughly a tenth of the
world's raw rare earth ore today. But for years afterward, a lot of that ore still got shipped
to China to actually be refined, because the mine came back before the refinery did.
Same hill, same rock. A different flag flying over it changes nothing if the
finishing plant is still 8,000 miles away.
So surely this fixes itself, America has its mine back, allied countries are opening new ones,
Australia in particular has real deposits, give it a few years and the choke point disappears.
So why hasn't it? Because the mine was never the choke point, the refinery is.
And building one from scratch isn't a supply chain decision, it's closer to building a
chemical weapons plants worth of infrastructure. Hundreds of precise separation stages, extreme heat
and acid at every step. And because most rare earth ore comes bundled with thorium and uranium,
a radioactive waste stream that has to be handled by design, not as an afterthought.
Today, real industrial scale rare earth refining exists in exactly three places outside China.
Malaysia, a small facility in the United States, and one plant in Estonia.
That's the entire non-Chinese refining capacity on earth. Building a new one,
from permit to output, takes the better part of a decade. Nobody budgets for a choke point
that hasn't closed yet. And the choke point doesn't need to physically close to work.
It just needs a form to sit on a desk.
The shipment's ready. It's sitting at the port.
Is the export license signed?
Not yet.
Then it's not moving. Doesn't matter what's in the container.
This is the trap, and it's the same one every resource choke point eventually teaches its owner.
You don't need to block the material, you need to control one signature the material can't move
without. A licensing office in Beijing can do more to an American factory floor
than a naval blockade ever could, and it never has to fire a shot to do it.
In April 2025, China added seven rare earth elements and the magnets made from them to
its export control list, timed almost exactly to a new round of American tariffs.
In October 2025, it went further, then suspended the new controls for one year as part of
a trade truce, but kept the April restrictions and the licensing infrastructure fully in
place.
Restraint, not retreat.
Then, on June 22nd, 2026, it added 10 more American companies straight to the list,
including two of the biggest rare earth names in the country.
Prices on some of these materials have already spiked sixfold.
European manufacturers report export license approval rates below one in four,
and that one year suspension from October runs out on November 10th, 2026,
a few months from now.
If it isn't renewed, five more rare earth elements snap back under full control, all at
once, on companies and supply chains that haven't had time to prepare for the first round, let
alone a second.
Nobody knows yet whether that deadline gets extended again.
That's not an oversight in this story, that's the story.
The leverage was never a one-time event.
It's a switch China can flip, loosen and flip again, watching exactly how much
pressure the rest of the world can absorb before flipping it back.
The mines can reopen.
They have.
The ore is still down there, same as it always was.
Digging it up was never the hard part, and it never will be.
Learning to finish it, that's the part nobody else built in time.
Until that changes, it doesn't matter whose flag is on the hill.
The stamp still says Beijing.